foreign
[Music]
so a cab driver in Queens got murdered
by the writers who tried to skip out on
the fair oh why does these [ __ ]
things keep happening and stuff what the
[ __ ] that's so sad man that's like dying
in ditch back in the day but then you
like have to run back to the kitchen and
kill the chef first and then like run
out yeah that's exactly the same like so
these people were just basically doing
the riding ditch in New York they get
out they try to run away he but what was
it like 40 bucks
yeah he ran after them to try to stop
him and then they turned around and they
clobbered them and hit his head dad hit
his head oh so it wasn't like a shot so
it was it was probably just like like a
punch to get away
but then they didn't want to kill him I
that's to be determined they're um were
they apprehended yeah and the prime
suspect
is a 13 year old girl
whoa she socked him that hard was she
geo-sized
big ass big ass [ __ ] man [ __ ] taller
than her dad and [ __ ] cause Jill looked
like she could one punch my ass out hey
daughters that are talking to their dads
we got problems man we have to release
the video before this you can't be
having no [ __ ] daughters taller than
their dads and [ __ ] daughter's taller
than their dad that her reach is
probably crazy yeah man wait the process
is a third is the is the Uber driver
[ __ ] like 79 no that's what's sad
he's just like a he's not like someone
you would think would you know just this
is him damn like he's not a is there
pictures of the kids that were running
away they're not gonna identify underage
people oh oh man bro yeah super sad how
many kids were in there doesn't say how
many kids uh but it just says the person
who delivered the blow that sent him it
was a 13 year old girl this is a taxi
driver or like ooh taxi was she wearing
like brass knuckles or some [ __ ]
probably caught him off guard ah just a
just hit him he probably grabbed her and
then just turned around a sock them or
something it was a 13 year old Samoan
girl dude from boy walking yeah but uh
is anybody familiar with like
um because she's a minor what does that
mean she probably won't be there's gonna
be a lot of Liberties yeah I mean it
depends they could depending on her
lawyer they could swing it where she
doesn't get tried as an adult they could
just but if this was the 90s and if she
was black they're gonna trial her as
adult oh yeah yeah but now I don't know
they might just wax it from a record
later on in life it could just because
they trial they um what do you call they
prosecuted a lot of underage
um kids as adults Back in Black kids
yeah they were like ruthless with that
[ __ ] uh Hillary Clinton called them all
super predators
holy [ __ ] yeah that was a thing more
than the Predator yeah no shoot yeah
they were they were they were calling
all the uh young black youth uh super
Predators
um and there's footage of this all over
the place too and it was weird because
it was coming from the Democratic party
so I was like dude that's [ __ ] up yeah
but we don't talk about that no we don't
talk about that now because it's all
woke right we only talk about how ugly
Chelsea you talk about reptilians I know
this is where I'm just like man it
doesn't matter if it's right or left
they're both [ __ ] [ __ ] like [ __ ]
them you know what's funny even Even in
our most like bone-headed youth when we
would do dumb [ __ ] yeah did you still
have an inkling of like I don't want to
hurt a person like this when I punch
people I didn't believe that they were
gonna die I just thought it was like a
movie where it's like you just have a
fist fight and that's it but I still
didn't want to punch an older person you
know like I I know some close friends
now that like you would never think but
like when they were younger mixed up
with like the wrong type of people you
know it's like hey we're gonna we're
gonna [ __ ] punk this person we're
gonna steal that lady's bag and you
gotta be the lookout you got to be the
person who's gonna like if if they have
a friend that rounds a corner you gotta
be the one that like hits him with this
bat type [ __ ] you know what I mean like
people are just involved in dumb [ __ ]
but it's not until an extreme shitty
circumstance pulls up that it's like you
know whether it be like a one punch
knockout the dude like hits something
that eventually kills him or like we
didn't know that this person was
actually gonna fight back and suddenly
now you're in an altercation that you
weren't expecting you know what I mean
that like that stuff's also weird though
because I remember like so being at that
age where we did a lot of crazy [ __ ]
there's also some sort of like like g
code where you're like oh they're not of
this world right yeah so if like someone
at Tapioca Express and starts talking
[ __ ] to you you just go oh you don't
want this smoke trust me you know you're
just like this is this is not part of
your thing but if it's like another dude
that's all locked the [ __ ] out you're
like oh dude Rumble all day or whatever
right or like you see a grandma you know
hey what's up you know Grandma looked
the [ __ ] up my game
I am blind these are [ __ ] looks
and she has Cortez's on game over just
like stretchy tattoos pulls her skin and
shows you all the ink stretchy texts
attack driver I
love older white dudes that start
stepping to you yeah then you're like oh
[ __ ] okay this is different you know
right but if they're not acting hard
there is like a you're not in my world
type of thing exactly yeah that's crazy
that is weird but I don't even know if
this game related just sounds like some
kids that were like dining and ditching
and it turned into an accident it
doesn't explicitly say it's Gang Related
but it kind of hints at it because one
of the charges that um this girl is
receiving she has theft of service and
gang assault
oh is it because it's they jumped them
I'm not sure if that term means that you
ganged up on someone or if it means it's
like a gang-related like a RICO kind of
you know like there's an organized Yang
assault just sounds like like jumping it
sounds like a group it could just be huh
like the term for just you know this is
weird because
they're not even Prosecuting in New York
so how the [ __ ] they're not gonna yeah
how the [ __ ] are they they're not
Prosecuting adults for this yeah so why
are they gonna do anything to her I
really don't think much is gonna happen
with this girl just in the current
climate of New York and you know they're
just as bad as we are here you know does
it say who she was with and how old that
person was uh yeah well it says that
she's the fourth suspect to be arrested
just in this case and another girl in
that group is 15. oh man it might be all
girls we don't even know how many fit in
the back seat but again it's harder to
identify and like get any info when
they're underage they just don't say a
lot yeah yeah of course but it is a
minivan minivan oh those taxis they
could fit a lot yeah five people in
there maybe damn that's kind of why like
you know um cab drivers at least have
the discretion of who they want to pick
up you know they'll just like pass you
by sometimes or at least with Uber you
can know their information well Uber
already has a card Associated yeah yeah
you know what I mean you can't just but
oddly that still doesn't stop people
from doing hood rat [ __ ] in an Uber I'm
surprised by that I'm like yeah remember
those girls that were like caught
slapping up a guy yeah and well nothing
happened to them too remember oh really
that's why people will keep on doing he
got charged and then she was out [ __ ]
breeding backyard dogs or something and
then she got rearrested for some other
[ __ ] completing dogs in the back other
[ __ ] like nothing happened so it didn't
even matter damn service industry people
got a tough they did they have it super
tough yeah yeah especially an Uber you
see all kinds of crazy videos of people
getting punched from the back seat and
[ __ ] throw that Taco Bell exec he was
like socking the guy out in the front
seat and then he found out he worked for
Taco Bell and then he got [ __ ] fired
so if you're if you're a CEO with a
cushy job you better not be punching
Uber driver now he works for Round Table
Pizza and he loves it he says it's great
over there and it's a promotion to him
yeah yeah he said they have a great
pizza get the King Arthur life couldn't
be better for this guy I remember
partying out in K-Town a lot and you
know like they have like their their
like underground Korean taxi service
where it's all word of mouth so it's
like you bypass Uber you bypass live you
bypass [ __ ] actual taxi service like
they have their own little own business
cards they have their own business cards
a lot of Korean people call it you know
what I'm saying and it's always on a
lighter a cigarette lighter so it's just
a like a little underground network but
the funny thing is because it's
underground right you're chat you're
transporting a lot of drunk people and
and this is one of those things where if
you leave your car somewhere you're junk
you can't drive it they'll sometimes
come with like two people so that
somebody also drives your car and drives
you home as well or some [ __ ] like that
right
um but you're dealing with a lot of like
drunk young Korean people that are
getting [ __ ] up all the time I
remember being in the car with one of my
homies homegirls actually in super junk
and just like throws up all over the car
no but you know this isn't like an
official business this is like that's
just a dude who also lives in K-Town
that's like his I need a plastic wrap
the whole back seat man well I mean I
think at the time like you know it's
early games like you learn you learn
over time but that it's just when you're
in an underground circuit you can't
really yeah you know there's nobody to
[ __ ] complain to there's no giant
like head of [ __ ] anything corporate
that's gonna reimburse you it's just
that was a shitty ride for the night you
know so that's why you need vigilante
justice have you ever ordered a grab
scooter
so like in Vietnam like they don't have
Uber they have grab and then a dude will
roll up in a moped and then you just
[ __ ] sit on the back seat and then
they'll have a helmet for you just go on
and then she'll take you to your
destination that's so personal holy [ __ ]
that's pretty personal like that's just
I mean they've always had that yeah you
know that's their taxi yeah I just
thought it was funny because like you
could also get food like that too yeah
so you get like food but you also it's
like Postmates yes you just hop on you
go all right let's go Bud I don't I
think I may have told you guys this when
I was in the Philippines and uh a bunch
of the guys we all wanted to rent
scooters and uh we just bullshitted and
he was like does all you guys have
motorcycle license like one of us did
there was like eight of us and we all
said we did so then he got I guess he
was confident did they check no they
didn't check so then we all get on these
eight scooters
and we're going through uh we're like uh
in the resort areas over in uh in like
uh what is that beach the one of the
like Resort islands and then um out of
nowhere this guy who's like leading the
group the guy who rented us the scooters
like this older guy out of nowhere he
goes oh I have to pick up my daughters
can you guys come with me to the school
so all of you guys just went in the
moped wait a minute there's not enough
room on his to pick up these daughters
so he he we go to the school and these
like like two little girls are there and
then one gets on his and I'm like where
the [ __ ] this other girl going and he
puts his other daughter behind Mine He's
trustful [ __ ] so she's just holding your
back yeah he's like it's okay we dropped
him up first and then we go Beach there
we go feed so then we [ __ ]
we as a group are going to this guy's
house to drop his daughters off this
little kid is holding on to me how old
was she [ __ ] is this like a little girl
like first or second grade
and then the crazy thing is like they
must do it all the time because she
didn't even think like he's he just goes
okay and then she just went picked my
scooter just went she goes on she's like
hi Uncle yeah and I was literally like
we were all like the [ __ ] is so it made
me extra shaky because like normally you
don't give a [ __ ] when it's just you
when you have a passenger you're not
used to it you're just more like careful
and that kind of hurts your you know
scootering yeah you got another life on
my hands right now dude that's something
wholesome about that yeah it is
wholesome but also like if I [ __ ]
spill and this kid just eats [ __ ] she
goes all right let's go she didn't have
a helmet she probably won't she gets on
one of your friends scooters that's it
next one hi Tito yeah when I do ride
slower out there yeah like in Asia in
general because it was like the resort
area it was very like hilly and
mountainy and [ __ ] and this dude does
not live like off the [ __ ] Main
Street
yeah I almost injured a grandma in
Vietnam
um from a moped yeah so I was like
trying to park she was laying on a
hammock in like the parking is above
this like little
this little ledge and so I had to like
push or I have to like go up to the
ledge fast enough to go over it yeah
yeah so instead of going slow I was just
like I don't know why I was so stupid I
literally just full throttled
oh [ __ ]
and then it literally went like straight
to her get some air I did like I just
went full throw I just I remember like
just going just sending it sending it
and then
um I saw the grandma and I was like oh
[ __ ] like I just think oh my God I'm
about to hurt her and then um somebody
like went and like got my scooter oh
dude that's lucky it flew out by itself
what do you mean the scooter flew did
you fly off of it or no I was on the
scooter so they grabbed it yeah they
grabbed it her legs were off the ground
I just imagine you hitting her on the
hammock and she goes
like
that could have been so bad
that could have been so so bad she could
have been really comical too
it's apology
comes back sorry
like a little cartoon yes would you get
mad at me
laughs
foreign